You know,
if you do a podcast and,
and the thing about the podcast with Jack,
it's not even,
like I said anything bad,
it's what I didn't say that that was upsetting to so many people.
But that's such a loaded thing.
And because of that podcast,
now there's,
there's negative to it that blow back.
There's a lot of,
you know,
toxic anger and all that.
But the positive is what I like,
the positive that came out of it is me forced to reexamine how I do podcasts,
reexamined the significance of each individual guests and especially someone
that comes with as much baggage,
you know,
without lack of a better term,
uh,
as Jack that you're,
you know,
you gotta think that there's people listening and there's some questions that
you really have to work at.
You have to,
you have to push through.
And even if he's,
he's dancing and pure wedding,
I should have went back to,
okay,
why is Kathy Griffin on your platform?
Yeah.
Like if doxing is bad,
you want,
you don't want a docs,
you don't want threat to violence.
When someone says,
I want names.
Okay.
What are you going to do with these fucking names,
right?
What are you gonna do with them?
What are you gonna do with a 16 year old kid and his names?
And then when you see the actual,
the actual video of what actually happened,
and there's so many people that are still not walking it back still.
No,
I know.
Doubling down.
A lot of people doubled down.
Fuck him.
And here's another little piece of insight.
My friend Matt,
uh,
lived in DC and those hats,
those mega hats,
they're fucking everywhere.
There's these little,
where these kids were,
that area.
There's these carts that sell these hats.
So these kids bought those hats that day.
It's not like they're these mag of kids.
They'd probably just be an assholes right there,
unsupervised teenage boys.
Their frontal lobe is not fully formed and they're all together,
feeding off each other like a pack of Gremlins.
Yeah.
I was a teenage boy.
You were a teenage boy.
You know how fucking stupid used to be.
I mean,
I was probably way more stupid than you,
but I was a mess.
I had my moments.
Yeah.
Um,
no,
I'd be just,
you get a hundred teenage boys together in a crowd,
you know,
on a school trip and you get some native elder drumming in one of the one in
some guys face.
Yeah.
You know,
it was amazing what didn't happen.
Exactly.
So violence,
no violence,
the way he handled it all.
He did a smile.
Yeah.
So I mean,
listen,
I'm as biased as anyone against a Catholic school kid wearing a Maga hat.
Yes.
Like you know,
like given,
given my backstory is like yeah,
I'm totally poised.
I think this guy is an asshole and this likely always to be an asshole.
But what people read into an uncomfortable smile,
right?
I mean just like the,
the,
the shots of his face with the tweets that said,
you know,
this is what white privilege looks like.
This is,
you know,
this is,
this is everything that's wrong in our society.
It's just we have to slow down.
How about raise a road if you ever seen them more Andrea punchable face.
Come on man.
You want to punch him?
Yeah.
Cause he's smiling,
which is call me.
Start on razor calls for violence from the left are so fucking disturbing to me
because my parents were hippies when I grew up.
I always thought of the left and we always,
I've,
you know,
I've been called right way.
I've never voted anything but democratic in my life except for Gary Johnson.
Gary Johnson was the only time I've voted independent or whatever the fuck you
was libertarian.
Right.
But that was just because he did my podcast.
I'll Tulsi Gabbard cause she did my podcast.
But the th th th th the left was always very considerate.
Well read.
They were,
there were the people that were more openminded,
there were supporting of gay people and minorities.
That was the left and there were nonviolent.
They were the people that are protesting Vietnam when I was a kid.
We're also just supportive of the virtue of speech and free speech and self
criticism.
Yes.
Right.
Like the,
the,
the disadvantage of the left against the right has always been there's this self
scrutiny and willingness to wonder whether or not I'm wrong.
That isn't mirrored if you go far enough.
Right.
And,
uh,
it has,
there has been,
so there's been kind of an asymmetric war between left and right.
You know,
politically from,
for much of our lifetime.
But you go far enough left now and you're,
you're meeting a kind of totalitarian resistance to speech and it's,
um,
yeah,
it's very,
I mean I'm just,
it'll be interesting to see how the,
the 2020 campaign plays out.
I'm certainly worried that we could totally blow it with some leftist social w
uprising.
Yeah,
that would be unfortunate because I think they would just double down the other
side.
We,
we'd be better off with some sort of a reasonable centrist.
Right.
Someone who has just made sense.
And you know,
one of the things that I liked about Tulsi is that she's a veteran and you know,
I mean like she's,
she seems very reasonable to me,
but except that I haven't followed her career closely,
but it just seems like she's not making the right noises on things like Syria
and Assad and yeah.
I don't know enough about that to comment.
I don't know enough about Assad and the controversial,
whether or not he'd gassed is whether,
I bet that that is,
I think,
uncontroversial in terms of what she,
I mean,
that that is uncontroversial with which,
in terms of what she is saying about it,
about him,
I mean,
she's capable of putting both feet in her mouth on that.
And she's saying he's not an enemy of America.
Right.
So,
yeah,
I mean,
again,
I'm not close enough to it and it,
but I would,
you know,
be very circumspect about endorsing her going forward.
And we could do a little homework because I think her candidacy is not going to
age well.
That's a.